breaking this afternoon the 215 in the
south valley is finally back open but
the investigation far from over after a
deadly road rage shooting on the beltway
left a driver dead and his passenger
fighting for her life the shooter on the
run this afternoon hector mejia joining
us now live near the 215 and warm
springs hector you've been out there all
morning into the afternoon any
information on the vehicle that police
are looking for
yes heather at last check police were
searching for a four-door gray-colored
sedan with up to four people inside to
left the scene right behind us and this
afternoon they're hoping someone saw
something
suspected road rage left a man dead and
a woman critically injured early monday
morning lieutenant david valenta with
the metro police homicide unit says the
shooting was first reported around 2 20.
the victim driver
was struck
causing him to crash his vehicle into
the center divider
before coming to a rest farther down the
road on 215. the investigation kept the
215 beltway closed near the airport at
the start of the morning rush hour
detectives spent several hours in the
eastbound lanes between las vegas
boulevard and warm springs as they
searched for clues anyone who saw
anything involving a couple vehicles
chasing each other driving side by side
cutting each other off anything like
that definitely give metro a call
valenta says they do not know exactly
where this initially started before it
turned deadly
both victims believed to be in their
mid-20s again if you know anything if
you saw something you were asked to call
metro police crime stoppers remember you
can remain anonymous reporting live
hector mejia live local now